a Christmas Carol adaptations range from
the delightful to the derivative just
he'll do the many iterations of Dickens
classic tale of redemptions stack herb
from the total disasters to the
heartfelt classics omocha here are a
Christmas carol adaptations ranked from
worst to best have you ever thought to
yourself that a Christmas carol could
use some slapstick animal gags undercut
all the Victorian gloom how about a
sleeker younger Bernese a Scrooge who's
given a second chance at love
perhaps a love song performed by Kate
Winslet no well that's too bad because
2001 s Christmas carol the movie is
stuffing all that and more into 81
minutes of tooth gritted cheer it's not
just that stuff that makes us take on
deck in so skippable despite that a-list
talent Christmas Carol the movie it's
remarkably lifeless the facial animation
doesn't ever look quite right the acting
is our best stiff and the entire
operation feels dumbed down this
adaptations fatal flaw is that it
doesn't trust Dickens and it doesn't
trust its audience this 2003 TV movie
attempts to liven up the classic tale by
replacing Scrooge with a selfish
talk-show host
and moving the story from Victorian
London to modern-day Hollywood it's an
intriguing idea on its own what setting
better represents a story of greed
empathy and false fronts on Hollywood
and hey isn't the idea of Scrooge as an
image obsessed celebrity pretty great in
concept is so strong and innovative too
bad the execution isn't a Carol
Christmas is little more than a fresh
coat of paint that flakes away over the
course of the movie revealing that it
wasn't all done necessary to begin with
the modern setting makes Dickens story
more cloying than anything else
removed from [ __ ] London a sickly
children and terrifying visions of the
future feel more like after-school
specials and grave warnings worst of all
a Carol Christmas is simply boring by
the end the audience isn't so much
watching the movie as it is waiting it
out the cranky celebrity might learn to
be kinder by the end but the viewer has
only learned to distrust new takes on
old favorites
there was a sliver of time in the 2000
when movies fell in love with surreal
motion capture powered computer
animation Robert Zemeckis fresh from
using this technique in the Polar
Express and Beowulf decided to apply it
to a Christmas carol led by performances
from Jim Carrey
and gary oldman as bob cratchit the
results were odd some like Roger Ebert's
hailed it as an exhilarating visual
experience others like the Telegraph
considered its looks distracting
creating distance between the characters
and the audience that made it difficult
to connect to the story this mode of
gravy than of grave about you whatever
you have years later the movies
reputation remains mixed and it's not
hard to see why there are certainly
strengths to be found Carrie Scrooge is
a bit goofier than other renditions but
it fits the ghoulishly funny tone of the
movie and Oldman scratches pitch-perfect
but the visuals so dazzling in 2009
looks strange to modern eyes plus the
tone of the film sits and comfortably
between two extremes it's a little too
dark to be heartwarming and a bit too
silly to be bleak only one thing is
truly clear it's nobody's go to version
when the holiday season rolls around you
might not recognise Alan Menken by name
but there's a good chance you know his
work The Little Mermaid Beauty and the
Beast and tangled all feature his songs
so when he signed on to a brand new
adaptation of a Christmas carol starring
Kelsey Grammer hopes were high the man
behind a whole new world and under the
sea tackling one of the greatest holiday
stories ever told that's just not a good
idea it's about - safer bet as anyone
gets in the entertainment industry and
yet somehow this version of Scrooge's
fateful transformation leaves something
to be desired the music is quite good
there it never hits the highs of
Menken's greatest work the story is
solidly told and the movie features a
fine performance from Jane Krakowski as
the ghost of Christmas past Grammer is
as grumpy as Scrooge should be without
ever crossing the line into total
awfulness and yets the entire affair is
somehow a nurse it never stops feeling
like something adapted from the stage
that probably should have stayed there
on film it never offends but it doesn't
impress either it's trapped between
worlds and able to succeed in either one
Disney has been involved in multiple
Christmas Carol adaptations but this is
the one that features a characters most
central to the brand Mickey Minnie and
of course Scrooge McDuck or star in this
particular take on the tale they bring a
certain lightness to even a darkest part
of the iconic story they want heads into
a Christmas Carol thinking Scrooge won't
end up changing his ways but they're
still
think soothing about Mickey Mouse
leading the bleak first half of the
story for the youngest viewers this is
an ideal Carol indeed unfortunately
that's the only group this version is
meant for anyone beyond the preschool
years won't find much to love about this
take blunted as it is by Disney's core
characters this isn't to say it isn't
sweet to watch beloved figures like
Daisy Duck and Goofy in London
learning the ways of goodwill toward man
that she had number of a Christmas carol
adaptations though means that no viewer
has to settle for mere sweetness leave
this version in the nursery where it
belongs and move on to something better
unique among Carol adaptations Scrooged
actually features an in-universe staging
of the classics Dickens tale shrewd TV
executive Frank cross ordered it and he
doesn't care how much strain it puts on
his overworked in place he is of course
the Scrooge of this story oh my gosh
does that suck he's even got an
overworked assistant a widow named Grace
and an old flame whose work with the
homeless contrasts sharply with his
Creed three ghosts visit him lessons are
learned and in the end Frank leads the
Carol crew in a rendition of the 1969
classic put a little love in your hearts
spins on Carol can go quite well and
this one does for the most parts modern
mass media suits our protagonists and
it's different enough from the original
story to be intriguing but similar
enough to translate smoothly Bill Murray
in the title role plays cross with
Sharky calculating menace he's a screw
see audience fears on a primal level as
he's so destructive in a familiar way
but there is a mean-spirited tone to the
film as though the movie is embarrassed
to seem too earnest this pairs oddly
with the sentimental ending which
actually goes further down the road to a
happy ending than most Carol's all in
all it's fun but only just this isn't
the only animated rendition of a
Christmas carol on our list but it might
just be the most visually striking so
much so that it won an Oscar for Best
Animated Short Film Richard Williams who
masterminded Who Framed Roger Rabbit
directed and produced this version and
the quality is clear in every frame this
version of A Christmas Carol is a steer
almost dour thanks to the crew looking
to 19th century in cravings for
inspiration
so this version might not be the one
children responds oh plus it's a short
piece only 25 minutes long you can't
help but wish the film had a little more
room to breathe if only to explore the
possibilities of its unique animation
more still the end result is a gorgeous
half hour of pure Dickens as
warm-hearted as it is to liberally rough
around the edges you forget the happy
ending within the grimy first half of
the tale so it's all the more delightful
to rediscover that in the second
Dickens work isn't exactly what anyone
would describe as feel-good sure a
Christmas carol has a happy ending but
the reader needs to earn it Dickensian
after all has become a descriptor into
itself and this version of A Christmas
Carol
aka Scrooge is truly Dickensian British
giant of the stage and screen Alastair
sim dunce a stovepipe hat in this
adaptation and he cranks up the
grumpiness to memorable levels
it's a notably grim take on an already
dark tale but it works for the most part
to do two sims unbeatable scream
presence you hate Scrooge but you never
give up on him that's tearing central
performance live-ins up the whole
production making the film actively
entertaining instead of simply faithful
to Dickens this is a deeply honest
Christmas Carol for better and worse but
it never loses his faith in humanity's
ability to change a version of A
Christmas Carol starring Patrick Stewart
already has a leg up on the competition
those who know his work will
automatically see him as a natural
Scrooge while those who are new to his
work will be quickly convinced his
gruffness suits the character perfectly
while his comedy chops come in handy to
warsi end she wrote as an actor at the
height of his powers and this adaptation
as natural rolling his eyes at orphans
as he is embracing Tiny Tim he gives the
entire production gravity and he loans
every scene in set-piece weights and
sophistication with his presence this
take on a Christmas carol helps you
understand how Stewart's Korea has if
anything only grown with age the movie
around him in contrast is merely fine
there's nothing to complain about but
beyond Stewart's powerhouse performance
nothing catches the eye that's easily
forgiven thanks to Stuart but when
plates beside other versions of the
story it's a lot more noticeable
Stuart's is talented enough to make
their production notable but in truth
he's the only thing that does happily
for Dickens and Stuart fans alike a
Christmas carol is very much a benissa
Scrooge's story thus this time is
Patrick Stewart story as well
what the Dickens have they done to
Scrooge the tagline of the Scrooge
poster please it's awesome a musical and
one made in 1970 of that you hear these
facts and imagine a source of perfect
anti Dickens storm approaching
and yet Scrooge actually ends up being
pretty delightful yes it enjoys summing
its knows that the ideas of the
Victorian era and what a literary
adaptation should be but it's heart is
fixed firmly in the right place and that
results in a truly wonderful rendition
of A Christmas Carol the son served the
story rather than smothering it
clarifying dickens themes as they spin
them into an entirely new medium is this
jaunt here than the more classical takes
on the story yes but that's a virtue
Scrooge might be making its own rules
but it never loses sight of its source
material there's no shortage of
Christmas Carol adaptations featuring
top-class talent especially in the role
of Scrooge but George see Scott brings
something a match to this version a
sheer power that pours from every frame
an actor from West Virginia brings
something to a roll is essentially
British as Ebenezer Scrooge saw the
actual Brits could do well to learn from
him this is a screw two strides and
whose nastiness stings all the more for
the force he could put behind it a
versatile so a Scrooge who feels
entirely transformed by the final
credits and a screw to deliver Samora
with renewed energy he isn't just
changed by his ordeal with the ghosts
but rebuilt as a new man with new
purpose alongside a cast that brings a
certain one quality many Carroll
adaptations like Scott shines all the
brighter it's not just a great take on a
classic story or a collection of
impressive performances it's a holiday
treasure all its own who'd have thought
that a rendition of a Christmas carol
starring Muppets would be one of the
best adaptations of all and like the
worst offenders on this list this film
doesn't just struts out the morals
everyone expects it also doesn't put any
unnecessary new spin on things that
don't need changing rather it highlights
the best things about the story while
providing a new lens with which to view
them thus it helps us love them like we
did the very first time we heard the
story to start with there's Michael
Caine Scrooge he's as grouchy as he
should be
but surrounding him with puppets teases
out a comical edge he's a terror but
you're laughing at him from the
beginning
this makes the movie an ideal choice for
the youngest viewers but it also gives a
film and inventive spin on Dickens tale
whilst some on this list succeed by
leaning into the story's darker elements
the Muppet succeed by embracing the
author's sense of humor joy and good
well first you will get to see gonzo
best numbers we're blue nose and love of
chickens take cultural cornerstone
Charles Dickens what's not to love what
makes a Christmas carol grace there's a
satisfaction of seeing a villain
confronted with the consequences of his
actions there's a slight sense of humor
that peeks out from around the story's
most cynical corners plus says the
community spirit that is celebrates but
beyond all that there's the hope it
Kindles a Christmas carol tells us that
it's never too late to be a bigger
better that's more benevolent person I
should change my way of living I would
try to keep Christmas or via it's this
spirit that the 1938 adaptation embodies
from its first scenes with sublime
ending it's a beacon of progress in all
its forms
Reginald Owen Scrooge is an old monster
who finds himself falling in love of
life again flush for the fact that it
isn't too late for him now this film was
made in the midst of the Great
Depression for a weary public remains
clear this is a movie for those all too
familiar with Scrooge and his ilk as
Dickens audience wasn't as day this
version of a Christmas carol understands
the power of its story like few others
and decades after its debut it still
shines like it did the day of its
premiere check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite Christmas
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]